your next movie is going to be with
Scorsese De Niro Leonardo DiCaprio you
know DiCaprio that's heady stuff to be
in a movie with De Niro right it is
um I I I wanted to just I would jump at
the opportunity to work with Scorsese
any actor what sure mastered Cinema
Creator and and and to be in that
environment for even the like three
weeks that I worked and only being
called in me a handful of times because
that's how he works you really stand by
he hires top shelf Talent no matter
where it comes from all over the country
and or world for that matter and
everyone pretty much just Waits until he
says okay we want to do this this and
this and you hop in the van you go in
and do it is that how it works did
that's how I did on this job it's
Scorsese seed the whale no no no it was
out of time I I had already done the
whale he might have known about the
project and considered that or someone
told him to but other than that I mean
he was really
um
just a regular
actor's director he moved furniture
around himself he likes to rehearse he
took suggestions he always you know got
the gave credit to the best idea
wherever it came from and but at the
same time he's brilliant because he
scores AC and he can solve like multiple
problems at the same time in an instant
and they're no kidding four cameras
quadruple uh quadruple coverage to shoot
um a courtroom scene that's happening in
real time like an opera
um it was remarkable to just I felt like
I was in the presence of like a
Renaissance master and everyone holding
up the tools and he just didn't you know
instructed everyone on what to do to how
to create the best best piece of Cinema
you you say he used four cameras for a
scene I always thought Scorsese would
only use one camera set reset the camera
and do reaction shots and everything
else but you say no he he will at least
that's what it was and on top of that he
shoots still shoots on film which is
great I for me because cameras today
that we use are digital they're like as
you turn them off you know a take goes
on and on forever like Darren Aronofsky
did the whale he loves to shoot many
many takes and that works for his
process but with um of course AC you
know you need to reload the magazine and
that gives everyone a break the pause to
catch your breath it's kind of a
different Rhythm it's I guess now it's
considered like an old school way of
shooting a film but it doesn't because
people don't use film anymore
infrequently infrequently I mean it's
probably what he knows I can't speak for
his process but
it's where he's most most at home it
would it would seem
foreign